NFL season just kicked off is the Super
Bowl halftime show something that you
would be willing to entertain fashion is
my first time hearing about the Super
Bowl since last Super Bowl I still got
an album to finish
back in 2020 Rihanna played koi about a
potential Super Bowl performance but now
it's official ree is set to headline the
2023 halftime show and a source tells
E.T she will give it 1 000 percent
on Sunday the Grammy winner posted this
snap on Instagram that's her tattooed
hand holding a football sky's the limit
no rules shortly after the NFL confirmed
the news ree is locked in for the
coveted halftime performance on February
12th Roc Nation the agency founded by
Jay-Z that heads the NFL's halftime
booking also confirmed the news in a
statement Sunday reading in part quote
Rihanna is a generational Talent a woman
of humble beginnings who has surpassed
expectations at every turn a person born
on the small island of Barbados who
became one of the most prominent artists
ever self-made in business and
entertainment I'm also really grateful
to still be here and being able to
expand into other Ventures and I'm
grateful it's been fun I can't even
complain riri's fans know she hasn't
released it an album since 2016's auntie
[Music]
chatted with the singer in 2020 she
teased that when she does drop new music
it will be worth the wait I'm always
working on music and when I'm ready to
put it out in the way that I feel fit is
gonna come out and you're not going to
be disappointed when it happens it's
going to be worth it I'm not just gonna
put it out just because people are
waiting like it's taken this long I'm
gonna make it worth it and back in
February shortly after Rihanna announced
she was expecting her first baby with
ASAP Rocky she gave us some hints that
new music isn't far away do you think
this stage in your life is going to
inspire new music oh gosh yes you're
still gonna get music from me maybe a
lullaby I can see you and ASAP dropping
Demos in the studio oh my goodness not a
lullaby my fans would kill me they
waited this long for a lullaby now a
source tells E.T that stars aligned and
it's the right time for the Fenty
founder to take the stage again quote
Rihanna never intended to take this long
of a break from performing it's just how
things turned out the source also notes
that while her fans have been eager to
see her perform again she didn't feel
like she was too far removed from the
stage everything she does is theatrical
and creative all her fashion shows her
book her makeup it's all part of her art
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
teases that Rihanna who gave birth to
her baby boy back in May will pour
herself fully into this massive
opportunity quote she no doubt has a lot
on her plate right now but she will give
it one thousand percent she will ensure
every detail is perfect it will be well
worth the wait
[Music]